reject nation I'm Greg Alba I'm John
Humphrey we're gonna watch some TV spots
for Star Wars the rise of Star Wars the
final Star Wars movie that's gonna open
up the door for more Star Wars movies
before we go into that we got ourselves
a sponsors today which we are very
grateful to be a part of and these folks
are hosting juh I think it's hosting her
hosting our hostess guys if you're like
us behind on the times behind all the
time and in need of the perfect hose to
build and protect your dream website
there's no better place in hosting earth
Palestine we only communicated via email
if you're not first you're last and to
be first you must be fast that's Ricky
Bobby's motto
no no it's hosting hers motto and they
live up to it we were able to set up our
first domain within minutes and shoes
from a variety of security options
hosting her also integrates seamlessly
with WordPress so you can get started on
a beautiful blog or web page in no time
so we got some hot takes you need to get
out about the last Jedi Batman V
Superman Matthew Perry's three to tango
get that blog started using hosting er
looking to start selling your personal
line of baby Yoda oven mitts open up a
nice tour or get a virtual private
server going and take your death
stranding or whatever a video game would
have been funnier to say at this moment
let's play through the people whatever
your hosting needs hosting our offers
fast load times 24 hour customer support
and for those of you watching this video
a full 91 percent off their yearly web
hosting plans when you use the cup Ricky
Bobby
no the real rejects well the real
rejects that's us if you're not first
you're fast that's what that's not visit
hosting er comm and get your domain
register today people
first ones duel
Wow
[Music]
[Music]
we'll see ray looking all freaked out
oh so excited for this I just finished
episode three account binging the Star
Wars movies guys I'm going in a timeline
order so I just finished episode three
last night I am on the train now that is
super hyped the Emperor's back just for
discussion purposes I'm excited about it
yeah yeah let's just keep moving on then
we'll talk more about some Star Wars in
a second next one is called and cuz it's
the final Star Wars movie it's the final
one
[Music]
the destiny of the Jedi
destiny hello
some shots
most of these are just gonna be like
moments from similar scenes just with a
few different shots one better shot you
didn't see portals yeah it's alright
celebrate
[Music]
December 20
the rise of Skywalker tickets now
I never realized bb-8 was leading the
charge they're so good
yeah getting me hyped like no eyes fate
confronting fear it's the destiny of a
Jedi a slightly different City the audio
oh that's a pretty clear shot good
people will fight if we leave them
yes
Star Wars the rise of Skywalker tickets
available now oh and they're even
advertising the videogame in this hell
yeah all right this one's called
adventure
he
whoa let the final battle begin
we make our last stand
ah
starwars the rise of Skywalker get
tickets now they interesting they cut
that to make it look like Poe was flying
that he was hoppin over la other weird
yeah it's a training exercise right to
kill her
I was a clone last one hold on maybe
they're gonna play the song hold on I'm
coming and you
[Music]
the destiny of the Jedi
[Music]
your destiny
[Music]
[Music]
and the impressions gonna be a lot more
humor in this one
oh wait looks like another one just
drops well we were filming this now it's
all the TV spots perfect this one's
called forever
[Music]
but people will fight if we leave them
they take enough of us now we take the
war to them
if the final
[Music]
seems like all these TV spots are really
honing in on the Savior heroic vibes
companionship and love really going to
the light side try balance all these
different tones have epic darkness but
also a lot of love and joy combined into
one my little theory everyone has their
theories about Rey with a double bladed
dark lightsaber should go to the dark
side is it a clone is it just a vision
I've heard one that she is the
reincarnation of Darth Plagueis a whole
bunch of things I'm gonna just throw one
out there probably won't stick but I'm
just gonna throw her out there I think
she learns to find the balance between
the good and the bad that the light and
the dark side from rewatching Episode
three being told about like these powers
the dark side has that Jedi just don't
possess Luke being tented by the dark
side maybe they are able to actually
find balance in the force and it's
through Rey that they find the balance
and so she embraces both okay here's my
theory it's a two-minute sneaking
sequence where she has to pretend to be
a Sith for a minute she unfolds a
lightsaber they're like she's cool quick
it's not even gonna mean anything it's
gonna be just like Rey's parents and
Snoke and everything else this seems to
really have sort of this like a B tone
to it for something that's also trying
to sell some epic harrowing final
chapter in the saga Nina was like is it
gonna be a difficult balance of what to
me it feels like very modern humor it
feels like very kind of self-aware like
oh we're acknowledging the sci-fi
elements of this that we're introducing
right now feels like Marley
yeah so not that that is a bad approach
by any stretch but I at least in the
glimpses of humor we've gotten in these
spots I'm a little distracted by I
really liked a lot of the just intense
imagery like the trailers have done a
good job at showing but these teasers
these little TV spots have condensed is
just the scope of like how huge all
these things are it really looks like a
big heavy movie yeah with how many like
giant ships are breaking out of stuff
the way that they keep advertising it's
literally every trailer the saga will
and this is supposed to be the final
chapter in the Skywalker saga one
cynical mindset that can pop into my
mind whenever they say that is like yeah
sure it's the last Skywalker Saga film
overs gonna be so much more Star Wars to
come kind of pitches on the the finality
I don't really feel like this is the
last one we need to go see it in there
to connect oh they're trying to kind of
manipulate audiences and the sort of
feeling that way you kind of get that
vibe that they're sort of aiming for
that yeah there's that little element
but in terms of just Star Wars my
journey would this has been interesting
is I've never done timeline binge order
before my appreciation for Star Wars and
my enthusiasm for it is actually like
extremely high my journey with Star Wars
has been kind of it's different right
now with all the news that's been coming
out with Lucas talking about how the
four seven eight and nine they didn't
follow like majority of what he
originally had in mind for what to
explore thematically plot point wise for
Episode seven eight and nine because
watching the prequels even the ones in
that I don't really like like Phantom
Menace is the one I just truly hate I
still kind of enjoy watching it because
I just like getting the information I
enjoy gathering yeah the lore the
mythology the background yadda yadda
yadda and I like watching how it's all
flowing so cuz by the time I got to
Episode three last night I was like you
know what watching Phantom Menace was
worth it to get to visable see the thing
is with those movies Star Wars does stem
from the mind of George Lucas and and
the bottom line is episodes 1 through 6
were still the original lore and it
seems like what they've been doing here
has completely went away from what the
original lore is and even though I've
really enjoyed force awakens
last Jedi there's pitching this as the
end of the Skywalker saga for some
reason I'm not really feeling the weight
to that it's like it's always been about
Skywalker and there's no Skywalker
presence really here for the film called
the rise of Skywalker
I haven't found myself as it personally
invested in the journey of Rey and Poe
and Finn as I have been with just
knowing the Skywalker lore before all
before force awakens came out I want to
see what happens and I want to really
see what happens with kylo Ren I'm
excited the Emperor's back weirdly I'm
not sure what to expect for this one
because they keep talking about
concluding it but you're like where's
this going you know yeah and I think
that's where the interesting part of
this journey has been for the with rise
of Skywalker is if you keep seeing all
these images and there's a lot of
speculation going around and they keep
saying tie it up I don't like I'm still
not even sure what this one is truly
about to me it feels like the the
Skywalker saga core people are kind of
at the wrap up of their story and
watching all these ads i also
simultaneously feel like all the new
people it's like so much to wrap up
there's like so much to do and so it
feels like to send off the original
characters what in this movie could
ostensively be enough but to wrap up all
this extra new stuff that like going
back to the point about cynicism early
on it does make me wonder like are we
going to let all the original Skywalker
stuff go and then just continue into an
episode 10 with rey Finn and Poe now
that we're not having any of the
original characters anymore is this
gonna wrap up everybody because it seems
like they've relied fairly heavily on
the older material up until this point
this movie seems like it has a lot to
accomplish I have no idea what to expect
from it other than like a lot of really
intense battle sequences yeah because
the thing is like all these images we've
seen look very sprawling there are a lot
of different locations and different
types of worlds that we're seeing and
they all look like there's action
happening on them so like I wonder what
the actual like dramatic thrust of yeah
that's what I keep pondering is what's
the emotional journey here exactly we
keep getting this quote from Luke
Skywalker
yeah confronting the fear like that
being that your destiny of a Jedi like
okay what's what's being confronted is
he scared of kylo now I don't understand
what's happening here itself is this
ending just the Skywalker stuff or are
they gonna do good episode 10 pick it up
for the new character yeah yeah yeah
yeah I guess my point would did not be
following the Lucas lore which initially
I was okay with but I'm wondering if I
might have a little bit of that Game of
Thrones final season effect where
they're like off the source material and
they don't have any framework yeah then
you know what I mean
we're like this isn't the real ending of
the Skywalker saga okay petition out
yeah remake it make all three George
Lucas to direct them all because yeah
don't get I'm gonna remind I do like
there it's it's it's a versus situation
I do like these movies I mean I I feel
like I'm probably gonna like this one -
but it's the films versus honoring the
lore you know I'm starting to understand
that debate better that I never have
let's bring up the last Genet arguments
again because now I'm started now I'm
starting to get that yeah yeah I was
wondering like once you get there maybe
you're about I've gone on that journey
with watching Anakin who's supposed to
be the chosen one evolve into Darth
Vader and then you get the heroic tale
of the rise of Luke Skywalker and then
they just started killing off we're
gonna hate am I gonna be on that train
by the time I get there cuz I've never
done this kind of binge before I've just
like watch them and kind of moved on you
know this time they're just gonna kill
all the droids and animal creatures it's
gonna be chewy Threepio r2d2 BBA all
them are gonna
and I got the Knights of Ren back your
day they got everything man yeah man
kylos got his old red fixed-up helmet
thing it's gonna be great I love how how
even the things they get to fix stuff
are stylish Lee cool my final point
would be this is a JJ Abrams directed
movie we all know that we would JJ
Abrams loves to do is like really build
a mystery and teasing without giving
anything away with its marketing that's
just what he does with his films he
knows how to entice an audience and hook
them in by intrigue to going to get
tickets to go see the movie and I feel
like that's what the marketing wants to
do yet it's just having me have a an
effect of I don't know what this is
about
yeah I don't really know what they like
somehow she's gonna get to the emperor
of iCarly yeah any like and the Emperor
stuff for this new trilogy is is all on
this movie like had like we've only
found out about the intent of having him
as of the teasers for exactly whereas
like the Emperor is well established in
the other trilogies like he's built up
in and one two and three he's built up
in the original trilogy and here they're
like no well it'd be different if there
were hints in one of the other ones that
he was back yeah alright guys well what
are your theories for star wars the rise
of Skywalker are you concerned at all
about how this is gonna turn out
do you have faith in it blah blah blah
leave your answers down below you guys
can subscribe to the real rejects click
that notification I'll get notified
whenever got a video up and we'll catch
you guys soon and don't forget get that
domain registered on hosting her and use
our code real the real rejects 91% on
Ron Burgundy run